it's great to see here tonight for the
season four premiere in the UK for Game
of Thrones if you could give your
character a Lauria some advice for the
future what would you say to her third
your loins you're in for a bumpy ride
and keep it cool keep a cool head and
and stay your course don't get too
hot-headed good advice definitely now of
course there's loads of great characters
in the show and you interact with some
of them and can you tell us what you
think of Cersei she's a [ __ ] but no
she's she Lena is fantastic I loved Lena
but Jesse's horrible she's horrible but
she said clever yeah but you know I've
joined now so head to head hopefully
yeah now we don't want to lose you yeah
you're just joining but if you had to
die in the show how would you like to go
out with a big bang oh gosh it's really
difficult cuz I've realised that I died
in quite a lot of stuff I do I've been
shot several times and come back from
the dead I've been hung I've fallen off
a balcony I've been shot with a bow and
arrow it would have to be something
spectacular
maybe burnt today I mean not me but
olaria you know all or drowned in sand
I like human burial you know like and
keep you gross but you know the clink
fairly near here they've got that I
can't get out of my head there's a cage
where they used to put a rat inside a
cage that was on top of your stomach and
then the rats couldn't get out so he
would eat his way out that would be
pretty awful
yeah that's like to comb like that but I
mean it might look great on telly
spectacular death
now George our masters taught recently
about the possibility of a game of
Thrones movie what do you think about
that I feel like you haven't finished
with the TV series yet and also the
beauty of television which we're all
learning now is that you've really can
give space and you can build on
character you can make them contradict
themselves bring it on TV you know
and finally what can you tell us about
what it's been like working with Pedro
Pascal because of course a great new
character like you are in the show -
yeah up Pedro and I got on really really
well and we had to be our love our
relationship in the show is really
intimate and intense but we're we're
experimenters if you like sexually
experimenting so we swing always but
there was a real trust between the two
of us and a sympathic oh and it was
really lovely to have a laugh and play
with them I felt safe that's great yeah
we look forward to seeing you on screens
thanks so much for talking to them dear
you